also meine these erhöht sich um karl
lauterbach ich bin fertig mit karl
lauterbach das ist auch nicht mehr
rettbar karl lauterbach hat versagt
jetzt als minister im amt ich will nur
an einen punkt erinnern
quasi unter seinen händen ist
es die impfkampagne verschiedenen
gestorben da ist nichts mehr von übrig
hat nichts dafür getan völlig schief
gegangen und hat ein problem mit der
wahrheit das will ich erläutern im
januar das erinnern wir alle gut ist ja
die der genesenen status ganz
überraschend halbiert worden auf drei
monate die leute waren entsetzt wie bei
vielen leuten war es ein schwerer
eingriff in ihr leben und
dafür haften musste bislang nur das rk
ii und dessen präsident lothar wieler
team waren schuld und zwar ganz alleine
wenn man sich ein bisschen um tod und
konkreter recherchiert stellt man aber
fest
am 14 januar hat das lka diese anweisung
auf seiner homepage veröffentlicht am 15
januar trat sie in kraft aber am 13
januar einen tag vorher schon erschien
sabine dittmar das ist die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin von
karl lauterbach im bundestag und
kündigte diese diesen abbau des
genesenen status an sie war die erste
überhaupt das rkw kann erst hinterher
als würde das rk hier sozusagen die
technischen einzelheiten verkünden aber
sie war die erste ich will dass genau
zitieren was sie da gesagt hat der
genesene status wird künftig nach den
mund nach nach drei monaten bzw 90 tagen
entfallen wörtliches zitat aus einer
kleinen rede sie war so stolz drauf dass
sie diese rede sofort auch homepage bis
heute anbietet
der bundestagsvizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki der die sitzung geleitet hat hat
mir berichtet den meisten abgeordneten
zeit gar nicht aufgefallen was sie da
gehört haben das passiert ja manchmal
das haus zur vorbei jedenfalls hat karl
lauterbach die gelegenheit ergriffen und
bis heute in allen möglichen interviews
erzählt dass er nichts davon gewusst
habe ich mit ihnen auch wieder wörtlich
zitieren aus einem faz interview
da hat er nämlich gesagt dass der
genesenen status über nacht auf drei
monate verkürzt wurde davon war ich
nicht unterrichtet ich nenne diesen satz
einen flirt mit der lüge denn werk das
nicht sage ich nur aus juristischen
gründen so freundlich ich würde sonst
hätte ausdrücken denn man kann annehmen
dass eine staatssekretärin ins parlament
geht um diese botschaft zu überbringen
unter minister weiß nichts davon da muss
man sich ja die haare mit dem fish usa
kämen um das zu glauben niemals außerdem
ist karl lauterbach bekannt als einer
der ministerium alles an sich zieht der
nichts an sich vorbeilaufen lässt und
eine parlamentarische staatssekretärin
hat ausdrücklich die aufgabe den
minister nach außen zu vertreten
der wusste nichts ich glaube kein wort
unten nach diesem seifigen dementi
erleben wir auch noch eine
weitere regierungspraxis eine
amtsführung er hat nämlich sofort jetzt
dem rk ii die vollmacht entzogen über
diese frage zu entscheiden er will
selbst entscheiden nach dem motto haltet
den dieb da macht allerdings die union
im bundestag nicht mehr mit denn die
haben begriffen dass man diesem mann
nicht vertrauen darf das haben sie auch
sofort öffentlich erklärt und sie
bestehen darauf dass der bundesrat
künftig an diesen unter unter
entscheidungen beteiligt wird stoppt den
antworten
hilft mir auch ein paar sätze es wird ja
wie die also die der bundesrat ist ihm
schon den arm gefallen nun wird es ja
noch wird die
die die die genesenen der spanne ist ja
inzwischen klammheimlich ohne dass das
viel darüber geredet wieder auf sechs
monate erweitert wurde aber nur für die
geimpften die ungeimpften bleiben weiter
auf drei monaten sitzen wir haben also
eine gespaltene geschichte und das ist
ja wirklich der höhepunkt wobei die
dreimonatigen ungeimpften das gar nicht
in ihre in ihrer zertifikat eintragen
lassen können in der apotheke wald das
gar nicht vorgesehen ist das hat ein
europäisches muster dass sie drei monate
gar nicht vor und das wäre ja und
nein ich mir auf meine konzerte aus
konnte ich lasse mich in dieser freien
zeichnung auch nicht zensieren
wir haben beide gleichermaßen da
herrscht jetzt das totale chaos und
verantwortlich ist carla macht deshalb
sage ich
ich will karl lauterbach
nicht mehr erleben wenn im herbst eine
neue ein neues virus über uns kommt dann
ich will auch nach dem freedom day am 20
märz von karl lauterbach befreit werden
der der gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ist gescheitert er ist
einfach nicht ministrabel dafür noch
sagen so jetzt
ich stimme in einem völlig zu dass karl
lauterbach einen sprung ins ministerium
nicht geschafft er war die ganze zeit
ein großer hoffnungsträger und es gab
einen riesigen druck auch auf olaf
scholz dass der mann minister werden
muss und es gibt in deutschland daher so
ein gewisses vorurteil man muss
möglichst vom fach sein und minister
sein zu können also am besten general
wird verteidigungsminister ist jetzt
auch ein bisschen anders und karl
lauterbach hat diesen sprung nicht
geschafft und was mich wirklich auch
stört deswegen stimmig dazu dass der
wlan oder schuldige ist erstmal völlig
egal was ich von den wiener haltet ist
völlig unwichtig aber es ist nun mal so
wenn man minister es wenn man irgendwo
chef ist muss man sich vor seine leute
stellen und herrlich muss man sie
rausschmeißen ja so und das hat er nicht
gemacht und das geht nicht dieses
lavieren da stimme ich völlig zu das
geht überhaupt nicht die hoffnung die in
ihn gesetzt worden sind nach hin sparen
sondern mal ganz nebenbei das war eine
große koalition und lauterbach und
spannend waren sehr eng unter war
ständiger ratgeber da ständig auch im
ministerium eigentlich gab es diesen
bruch nicht er wollte was anderes
darstellen und ist daran meines
erachtens wirklich bisher nicht gut
gefahren ich finde ja dass ein bisschen
schnell dass jemand nach drei monaten
gehen soll welches erledigt bis zum
herbst
will ja nur darauf hinweisen er ist im
moment der beliebteste politiker
deutschlands
liegt für ein eigentlich das müsste
eigentlich
ist lauterbach hauptverantwortlich dafür
dass wir einen fürchterlichen
mentalitätswandel in diesen in diesen in
diesen zwei jahren hinter uns haben
nämlich zu einem obrigkeitsstaat und zu
einem regieren aber die angst und ich
muss sagen wenn ich etwas beunruhigt ist
es nicht dass masken tragen in
innenräumen ich bin ich bin ich bin
grundsätzlich ein vorsichtiger mensch
ich habe schon sagrotan benutzt das
buchstabieren
hatte daran domestos gedacht ich war
schon immer vorsichtig aber ich lasse
mir nicht meine eigene vernunft nehmen
und lasse mich und ich entscheide selber
wo ich vorsichtig bin und wo ich zettler
ich bin einer frischen luft schon von
polizisten in bayern aufgabe
aufgefordert worden eine maske zu tragen
habe sie natürlich an gezogen und sofort
wieder abgelegt weil ich zwei schritte
weiter gehen ich mache ich möchte ich
finde es höchst beunruhigend dass ein
mann der hauptverantwortlich dafür ist
dass wir über angst regiert worden sind
sind dass der plötzlich der beliebteste
politiker sich machen wir haben stimme
ich hier stehe ich mache mir große
sorgen über den mentalitätswandel in
diesem in diesem land ich glaube wir
haben was wir jetzt erlebt haben ist ein
glimpflich davon gekommen mit diesen
sicher tückischen virus ich bin
überzeugt dass es werden schlimmere
krankheiten auch auf uns zukommen in
zukunft aber wir haben die generalprobe
als demokratische gesellschaft nicht
bestanden und das ist für mich nicht
eine frage der maske sondern sondern
sondern die aufteilung zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften dass wir
menschen zweiter klasse haben hätte ich
nie geglaubt dass wir das leben
und das gleiche gilt wenn ich auch für
die regelung mit johnson & johnson das
hatten wir jetzt gar nicht gesprochen
also genesenden status ist das eine aber
auch dass johnson & johnson und mit
einer impfung da hat man die
auffrischungsimpfungen dann gemacht
vielleicht freiwillig weil man sich
gesagt hat was sollte ich mal lieber
machen und auf einmal gilt der status
nicht mehr stimmt und man muss sich
erholen obwohl es eben noch vor einem
halben jahr hieß johnson & johnson ist
sicher sehr richtig es gibt ein es gibt
einen schleichenden wechsel zum
autoritären dafür steht auch karl
lauterbach warum hat er die vollmachten
an das rk ii und das an das
paul-ehrlich-institut
abgegeben weil er vermeiden wollte seine
pläne in der koalition mit der fdp
streitig zu diskutieren die hätte ihm
bei manchen in den wehren in den arm
gefallen oder im bundesrat mit der cdu
also wird das ganze als
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis ausgegeben
und wissenschaftler entscheiden darüber
wie wir leben was ist denn dann übrig
von der demokratie und also hole ich las
man das als lob gescheitert gottlos ist
ja so dass wissenschaft schon rolle
spielen soll aber im grundlagenbereich
entscheidend jahren wir ich finde
allerdings für mich mit das größte
problem bei karl lauterbach ist bis zum
wahltag hat in deutschland ungefähr
jeder gesagt es wird keine impfpflicht
geben noch voll auf scholl karl
lauterbach der gesagt hat im pflicht und
das ist für einen gesundheitsminister
entweder ich sage die regierung setzt
das durch will das durchsetzen weil sie
den entsprechenden gesetzentwurf oder
ich sage aus der mitte des parlaments
dann allerdings halte ich mich zurück
ich meine olaf scholz und ähnlicher
weise zu aber für karl lauterbach noch
mehr denn erst gesundheitsminister und
hat damit natürlich ein seine autorität
eingesetzt der zweifellos hat er ist ja
medizinisch vermutlich bewanderte als
wir alle aber die darf man eben nicht so
einsetzen für sony als aber muss ja
nicht wenn es um eine
gewissensentscheidung gibt das ist das
ist wirklich ein großes problem es wird
immer gesagt ist eine
gewissensentscheidung und dann darf man
nicht von dieser position sagen ich bin
für die impfpflicht und jetzt muss es
auch durchgesetzt werden weil es geht um
den gesundheitsminister um den kanzler
es geht ums ganze und das macht
natürlich eine solche entscheidung
unendlich schwierig ich kann die leute
verstehen die für eine helmpflicht sind
ich bin dagegen das ist aber jetzt kann
man diskutieren da soll man einen freien
austausch eine freie entscheidung zu
lassen und das ist durch ihn behindert
worden und das finde ich nicht zulässig
wenn man zu machen